seguir atención entre rusia y ucrania el
gobierno ucraniano convocó un consejo de
ministros extraordinario para hoy mismo
ante una probable invasión rusa del país
esta misma semana podría producirse
según dicen algunas fuentes un portavoz
del presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski ha insistido en que las
aspiraciones de ucrania de unirse a la
otan y a la unión europea están
previstas en la constitución y siguen
siendo la prioridad absoluta del país
sabéis que ha recibido el apoyo en este
sentido de países como gran bretaña que
ha dicho que respaldará cualquier cosa
que ucrania decide hacer respecto a su
ambición de unirse a la otan lo ha dicho
el ministro británico de defensa
mientras tanto desde washington dicen
que la puerta a la diplomacia sigue
abierta y aquí en moscú llaman histeria
a las advertencias de eeuu sobre una
posible invasión rusa mientras tanto el
gobierno ucraniano ha aportado 590
millones de dólares para mantener el
tráfico aéreo mediante seguros de
aviación en medio de una oleada de
cancelaciones ante una amenaza de guerra
que está lastrando ahora sí y mucho la
economía ucraniana